it is September 11th I guess we should
probably talk about that in 17 years if
a child was born in September 11th they
can drop they've been able to drive for
a year yeah and they're like I was
senior year of high school and it was
like first first period whatever it was
my first period bleeding for the first
time I think it probably was around that
time and and I just we were reading King
Lear and it was the scene where his eyes
get poked out and I remember my teacher
mrs. Larson being like today is like a
rough day cuz we're gonna be reading
about like this really gnarly scene that
happens and I just want to prepare you
for it and then I heard the intercom
just like and we didn't get
announcements until after second period
so I heard the intercom go like I heard
it turn on and I remember in that moment
being like something serious
happened just hearing a like that and
then my best friend's dad who was our
principal got over and was like teachers
turn on your TVs and I remember I was
the same as you Tom I go if it we turned
it on I go what's the World Trade Center
yeah and I remember mrs. Larson going
like you don't know what the World Trade
Center and I remember being like that
day my like morning like that was my
emotions like being shamed tell your
teacher mommy on accident we're gonna
make fun of you for for the rest of
school mommy that's a common thing
though there's I have teacher friends
that are like I get called mom at least
like once a month
oh of course and but by the way mommy is
so much worse than mom ready mommy I
think that's why you use mommy as a joke
so often because it's like something
that really stuck out to you it is so
humiliating still hit you up on Facebook
hey mommy I cut all those people out I
wanna talk about more embarrassing
moments like that because that just like
really tickled my soul I'm sure that you
guys have them as well we'll get to more
if you've done something so embarrassed
if you got an embarrassing story that is
literally the most embarrassing thing
like try to top saying mommy calling
your gym teacher mommy in what grade
probably I was probably the first or
second grade my college to the show 84
for comedy 9 we'll be back after this
and we're back with more show we're
talking embarrassing moments on the show
today mat fault Ron you got one for us
yeah I was 19 and I came back from lunch
I was in college I was a went to my dorm
I don't walk into my door and these
three girls are just like I was a coed
dorm and they were like oh there he is
I can't believe you showing your face
tonight and I was like what do you
talking about like you don't remember
no like you walked in our room last
night we were all hanging out you opened
up the laundry you know like the laundry
box or whatever with the lid on it and
pissed in the laundry box and then like
closed it and walked out because
it was right where my toilet the toilet
in my parents bathroom was I was like
sleepwalking
it's like the first week of school no
that's always so humiliating when and
then that's yeah I ended up being
friends with them they didn't care that
much but now I think it's sexual assault
yeah that's worse but in that moment you
were like that was like the you words
what did you say I didn't believe them
right a sleepwalker you know mister
no I've never done that before I had
about three beers I don't think that I
don't think maybe I mean possibly yeah I
was a lot of weight a lot less than but
three beers I don't know I think that
sleepwalking
I mean I don't know when I think like
what would Mike Baldwin do of an
embarrassing story yes I was I was
probably 21 or 22 and there was a girl
named Jessica McDaniel who I went to
high school with and I had a crush on
her since like freshman year and like
never did anything with her or anything
until this one night when I'm 21 or 22
we're at this party I don't remember
where it was I remember it was a brick
house and I'm like sitting on the porch
and I'd been drinking tequila all night
long and she'd been drinking something
apparently because that came up and
she's like you want to just make out or
something and I was like oh yes and we
started making out for like five seconds
and then I just immediately started
crying and she just like the look on her
face of like wow dude and I just and
then my me crying made me cry more and
I'm like I don't know why I still think
about it at least once a week and cringe
about does it make your whole body tense
up it sure does that do that at least
once a day oh my god that happened
[Music]
it's one I forgot I tweeted this the
other day it was during a breakup so was
embarrassing in a big room since but
just for me I still think of Italy where
this girl I dated in college broke up
with me we were hanging out of her place
and just out of nowhere we started
talking about like yeah I don't think
this is working out and I was devastated
and I was just like alright well I guess
it's over and so I I got up and I was
like I guess I'll just go then and then
as I was out of her door I
thought I heard her say something I was
like what music I didn't say just keep
wait one girl called in and she could
that reminds me of a story that a girl
called in and now her calls gone back in
you had a thing where a guy said
something to you and you misinterpreted
what he said let's go to Dugan and
Sacramento Dugan how are you good Dugan
tell me what happened what's your most
embarrassing moment well I just want to
say that it's not as bad as calling
somebody mommy about 12 years old coming
home from soccer practice got a ride
with a family friend and a player and
both my mom and dad's car home and I'm
like wow that's that's really strange
you know it's favorite they would have
picked me up from soccer practice so I
didn't really think of it too much and I
walk into the house and there's my mom
and dad just going at it down the
kitchen table I had you know I was 12 I
maybe be like some Playboy's and stuff
so I was like what's this
so to the neighbor's house and you know
she was like this elderly grandmother
Lee type of the neighborhood and she was
like how could you just come home from
soccer practice milk and cookies and it
was just like what I needed at that time
and then I walked home maybe about a
half an hour later and my dad was
sitting in the front you know in the
dining-room area he's like we need to
talk we're sending you to boarding
school so your parents all you see them
I think my dad but I'm pretty sure my
dad like heard the door like crack and
like look around
they really hot back then though right
did he have a talk with you about Lehane
son I know what you saw or was it like
it was that we had led into like you
know here's the good news the talk is
going to be way easier than the
intro what that sucks when something
embarrassing happens to you that you
walk into and then you have to do like
seeing someone else jerking off or
whatever but I would hear the worst
story that someone has about sending the
wrong text to someone cuz I think that
that is seriously kind of the worst like
that fills me with if that happened to
me I just this dude that we all hated
and then his parents it was it like we
were like 19 and so we would drink it
there his parents place
they were the family that's like you can
drink but only if it's under our roof or
whatever and their party sucked or ever
so we left and we tried to come back and
I sac was like well you left says
you man you can't come back and I was
just I tried to say
my other friend like man Zack
sucks and I sent it straight Tuesday and
then how do you deal with that I was
just like you're pissing me off I just
acted like I maybe yeah I haven't sent
like a talking text on accident but
I sent I told you this story recently
I've sent a group chair oh my god Mike
this is so holy mike is so stupid an
adult this was on it was on Thanksgiving
and it was probably like almost 10 years
ago was my first iPhone or at least the
first iPhone that had group chat
capabilities and I sent like Happy
Thanksgiving milady
like I hope you have a day as beautiful
as you are or something like that and
sent it to like 10 girls and didn't
realize that it was a group chat so then
the first reply is like oh thanks Mike
you're so sweet and then the second
reply is wait Mike did you send this to
more than one girl and then the third
reply is from the third number that's
like yep I think he did they all just
continued talking to each other on my
group chat and I was like I want to die
right now and they're like it's fine
like don't worry about it but that's
another one that I crane well I got I
got one for you I I was dating this girl
she lived in Kentucky she sent me a nude
picture of herself and I said hey this
is uh you sent this to someone else
and she goes no you know cuz I saw two
numbers in the top okay you sent this to
someone else she goes no I just took it
this is just for you and I'm like no you
sent it to another number too she said
it to her cousin as well
[Music]
wait let's go - she was racist adjusted
in North Carolina I've really I've just
read the excerpt of this story Justin
tell us don't don't read it till I
wouldn't design well Justin what
happened to you
well I actually back in my 20s I was
near sounds like North Carolina yes yes
I am it um I had my wisdom teeth removed
and my wife took me to have the surgery
done and uh we came back home I was
still very into hearing with medicine
and I guess some somewhere in that
timeframe my mother came over to visit
while I was still in bed and I thought
that it was my wife and I told her that
I wanted to taste her and it was
actually my mother wanted to taste her
that did you did they tell you later on
that you'd said that or did you like in
the moment go oh actually my wife
no luckily thank God there was no video
but my wife was standing kinda in the
background and heard me my mother did
not acknowledge it at all and uh later
on my wife's told me about it so pretty
embarrassing Oh God God
yeah okay let's go to Brad and Michigan
he sent a text for the wrong to the
wrong person what happened there so I I
was in a new relationship so kind of a
hot and heavy section of it and I was I
had a little side job or I was painting
houses and I was painting a house for
this there's older lady and I sent her
the words are we gonna tonight or
what oh boy did she reply she did she
said well I hope not
oh that's great but then I had to finish
the painting job so that was no I am I
once was having really really loud sex
in an air B&B that I had rented and I
got a text this was really embarrassing
I never had to see the guy again but the
guy whose place it was texted me that
hey we got
my landlord called last night and
there's there was like screaming coming
from your apartment I just want to make
sure everything's okay and um and I was
like does he know that I was having sex
or is he really checking in on like if
everything's okay like I didn't know how
to really handle it yeah so I was in the
writers room for my show at the time and
I remember Benji Alf Lalo one of my
writers was like just tell him you were
auditioning like you were practicing an
audition and so I wrote back and was
like oh I had an audition where it was
like I was like I have to scream a lot
I'm really sorry and he's like okay like
he wanted to just feel like I was having
sex man like I just wanted it but like
that was embarrassing because oh and
then another time I was having sex with
my boyfriend and I think the most
embarrassing times have been when I've
heard that people have heard me have sex
later on it's so embarrassing like and
I'm not someone who's trying to be heard
like I when my ex and I used to have sex
in this one time we were staying with
his cousin uh-huh in Chicago and both
his brothers were sleeping in the living
room and we were in a guest room and I
was trying to be so quiet because I
didn't want his brothers to hear me
having like there's no way that's not
something I get off on or like whatever
one and the next day they were like you
sounded like they were like hey Wolfie
they called me Wolfie and I was like I
didn't understand and then it was like
an inside joke that I sounded like I was
howling like a wolf like they all every
one of his friends because he has friend
that he lived with roommates I'm really
loud when I have sex and I didn't know
that and I don't know that and and it's
just but then and also and one of my
most embarrassing moments is on camera
from when I did not safe I was um my dad
I gave my dad a lie-detector test and
one of the questions that a writer wrote
was like have you ever heard me having
sex oh god I remember asking that being
like just please be like but I lived at
home and had a lot of sex like at home
and I lived at home with my parents with
my ex-boyfriend and um and my dad has
heard me have to tell me that he heard
me was so humiliating oh that's not safe
I was not has he ever walked in on you
or your mom one time a guy was inside me
in my bedroom and my dad knocked on the
door and was like hey Nick and I was
like I'm talking to my dad well there's
a dick in me like I cannot believe I
have to and I was like I remember like
there's someone in me and I'm talking to
my dad it's like this is the way my mom
walked in on me by myself once Oh
jerking off yeah yeah like him like
pants off jerk like not just a quick
like I could just pull up my waistband
or whatever like there was nothing that
I could do I'm just gonna go through
some of these Joshua and Newton North
Carolina accidentally sent a dick pic to
his commanders slash leaders instead of
his fiancee just salute Oh Kyle let's
talk to you about Kyle what what did you
send what - I picture - my mother-in-law
what did she say um well as much as she
can be she thought it was very nice but
we went over to the house she got very
beet red whenever she saw me beet red is
right sometimes when I meet porn stars
or I meet people who have had sex tapes
like I don't it's weird to see that
because you're like I've seen your dick
like you know like I have a joke you do
well I'm just like I like when girls in
porn look like girls that I know in real
life but I don't want to know a girl in
real life that does porn yeah because
then I'd have to like hang out with her
and she's like okay so what TV shows do
you watch or whatever and I'm just like
your butthole can get really big guys
I've slept with like I feel like I'm
friends with a lot of guys whose dicks
have been in my mouth and inside me and
it's just whenever I'm just like with
them I'm just like oh my god that's so
weird
right you're like how are we talking
about your kids right now
when like your dick has been in my mouth
I feel like that's the only thing we
should be talking about it just like
it's so weird that you just like move on
with life and okay let's donate let's go
to Tony in Montana what what happened to
you tones it was before the a I couldn't
I didn't have access to porn before
cellphones and all this and the hottest
thing I could get my hands on was
grandpa order Jerry Springer uncensored
oh hell yeah I was in there and I was
choking it in his chair in the morning
yeah watch drumming full stroke about to
about to you know and then grandma walks
in she goes Tony and I just immediately
I didn't know no chef I could go that I
could go left off that quickly that's
possible and then I go back into bed and
my bed with my bedroom when I stayed
over that house was near her and I hear
her giggling I wanted to shoot myself in
the head about 14 yeah that's that's
definitely and there's Jerry Springer
tape but they're fighting and their
breasts came out of what it was a cowboy
stripper chick lingerie JCPenney I mean
these kids don't know you could make
anything work back then target so crazy
like that the simplest thing and now
it's and now it's like I want to see two
dicks in her ass at the same time
where's the two dick in the ass video
see this is why I don't watch porn a lot
because I don't want to be sensitive
that time when my mom walked in on me I
was watching the grind on MTV which is
which is just like they would play music
and people would dance yeah but it was
like you know skimpy clothing man that
girl with the long socks and the short
skirt on my
yeah anyway yeah now I just breeze past
Instagram accounts like it's nothing I
would have killed for that when I was 13
right I am yeah I can tell right now
that you watch a lot of anal porn you
mentioned it twice I really don't wanna
turn I'm not I don't go for anal porn
sometimes it's like you know like girl
gets hard by a guy and I'm like
alright that seems okay and then it's
directly in her ass and I'm like you
should mention that I feel like that's
another thing I don't like about boy I
feel like that's just implied now if
it's sex at all
eventually anal so angry what I'm
watching a video and anal doesn't happen
I really do I'm like I find that that
too many don't end in anal and I need a
no in my porn I don't need it in my
personal life every time but in my porn
like I need a girl to take it in the ass
like that's where I'm at right now I
feel like usually there's like like a
dance to it where it's like like oral
then the regular pan then they go to
anal and then they go back to oral right
right atm baby damn machines digging
that yeah let's go to Lola's she's been
waiting a while I want to hear about her
an accidental text you sent what who'd
you send it to um so I was um I saw one
of the one of my co-workers called in
sick and it was on a group chat and I
texted who I thought because my manager
was to bitch about it and so he kind of
text me back and it's really subdued
like okay well I'll see you at work and
I texted I was like oh shoot I think I
texted him privately I was like we're on
the group shot and he was like oh all of
your numbers came up no and it was it's
one of these people that like is very
very very very sensitive very like it's
worked up really easily and what do you
do I mean like that is that is my
biggest fear I need to stopped
talking on text because that is
bound to happen to me it's almost one
time I sent a text to my ex-boyfriend
that wasn't meant to about him he was
late for a flight that we were catching
and it wasn't his fault and I was like
he's late again and he was so
mad that I had that tone about him to
someone else and he should have been
like but it in that little mistake I
can't imagine if you're really really
laying into someone and you send it
that's why you should never you should
always have nicknames for people
sometimes you gotta call somebody if you
want to talk sometimes you just
gotta make just yeah that's a good point
you know I can't think of anything like
you up you know I think like farting
when you're not when you don't mean to
fart is one of the most embarrassing
things that can happen to ya a girl or a
guy for sure like when you accidentally
fart like I those moments to me stand
out so much have you ever accidentally
burped when you're yawning like that
little throat noise a weird noise came
out when I was like on a date recently
and I like just got really loud after it
like make him forget that I don't really
weird it's the voice equivalent of
jogging a little bit when you trip over
there I'm just just joking a little
sudden or just like getting angry at
whatever's around you when you really
are just mad at yourself like I fainted
on stage once and that was like my I
lashed out at the crowd for like not
helping me when really I was just like
mad at myself and now you really fainted
on stage that was my most embarrassing
moment
like were you out for a long time or
about 510 seconds okay yeah but like
fully fainted passed out fell on the
stage I fainted at a party once and woke
up and everybody was still just laughing
at me
so it was like short enough time I did I
killed at that party it was death
deafening silence when I fainted they
did almost what that's what woke me up
was that the audience that had been
laughed like everything stopped but
maybe they assumed that you were in the
middle of a bit or they did they did and
I was not a lot of them were like oh we
thought we were joking I'm like what why
is that funny like I'm funny that isn't
I was offended that they thought I was
like a stunt comment somewhere yeah like
I've seen comic strip getting on stage
before and like the audience just assume
assume that's what he does at the
beginning trips and falls
[Music]
you